the Romero family have gathered to bury
their 90 year old mother who died of
coronavirus in a care home two weeks ago
they say she would have wanted a big
funeral with all her family and flowers
but under the lockdown large gatherings
are prohibited every 10 minutes
another hearse arrives there isn't much
time for goodbyes
each coffin is wrapped in plastic to
protect the living they try but it's
difficult to give the dead the dignity
they deserve in a pandemic
the priest flicked holy water at the end
of the service and then it's over and
another one beginner's el número a
virtual era vs DOS a persona pero con
esta situación muy agribon t su bel
numero según la capacidad enter venta
cinco a treinta persona even grieving
here has to be done quickly and without
much support only three family members
are allowed to attend they wear gloves
and face masks for their protection some
live stream the short service so other
relatives can pay their respects in a
Catholic country though where family is
everything it is painfully not enough
we're watching another funeral take
place now they are continuous and it's
heartbreaking but this is the reality of
what life is like here now even the most
intimate of act burying one's loved ones
is taking place under severe
restrictions not all the family can
attend only a few members can come they
weren't protective clothing and they're
having to stand apart to prevent to
limit the spread of the corona virus
in another Church across Madrid people
are storing the ashes of their loved
ones because there is a huge backlog of
services that need to be carried out
Spain's coping but it's not easy
adjusting to a new way of being where
death is everywhere
father Ignacio and 3oh says people need
the church more than ever in these dark
times
coochi elements are integral and he was
tough he is now harnessing the power of
the Internet to minister to his
congregation to meet social distancing
rules daily services a live stream to
the faithful in their living rooms it's
not the same but it does allow people to
connect and hope for better times
Alex Rossi Sky News Madrid